I once said in fact he said it to me if
I may drop another name some people
wouldn't think that's such a great thing
to drop complained about the fact that
all American Jews seemed to be doves on
Vietnam and hawks on Israel and where he
couldn't quite reconcile that
contradiction and there was a strong
anti militaristic streak in the liberal
culture and most American Jews were then
and still are for reasons that I won't
go into at the moment liberal but I
don't quite agree with your analysis of
the Middle East except to the extent of
your accepting your point that that
there's not going to be any peace in the
foreseeable future and much more likely
to be in my opinion a major war but the
way you describe the situation is too
much what we used to call during the
Cold War
case of moral equivalence I don't think
there's mutual hatred between the Jews
and the and the Palestinians or the Jews
and the Arabs actually the Israelis have
for all practical purposes been begging
for suing for a peace agreement with the
Palestinians by offering under this
latest prime minister the most
extraordinary and I think dangerous
concessions which have been not only
rejected but answered with another
outbreak of violence the so-called
Intifada - even though Prime Minister
the current prime minister Barak offered
them a share of sovereignty over
Jerusalem which no Israeli Prime
Minister would ever dreamed of doing and
95% of the so-called occupied
territories and various other
concessions I believe that
you
poets and so I'm gonna try to bring the
two things together in the context of
the history of the time what what they
meant historically and what they still
have to say to us today which I think
differs from what many people who are
even aware of the prophets imagine they
are saying to us also to be published by
Free Press that's right in depth Norman
Podhoretz thanks very much for spending
us three hours with us today that's
three hours I spent maybe my life thanks
very much you've been watching in-depth
with Norman Podhoretz this program will
be repeated in its entirety tonight at
midnight Eastern 9 p.m. Pacific 48 hours
of nonfiction books on TV you're
watching book TV on c-span - next month
on book TV a conversation with Nobel and
Pulitzer Prize winner Toni Morrison as
Morrison is a professor of humanities
[Music]
if you'd like a videotape copy of the
programs you've been watching this
weekend or any weekend on book TV call
one eight seventy seven on c-span for
pricing information or to request a tape
or go online to c-span org slash shop
and click on book TV next journalist
David Harris talks about his book on the
US government's 1989 arrest of former
president of Panama general Manuel
Noriega after its invasion of the
country it's titled shooting the moon
the true story of an American manhunt
unlike any other ever his comments are a
little over 50 minutes good evening
I'm Elaine Petrocelli and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to book passage
tonight to celebrate the publication of
David Harris's latest book shooting the
moon the true story of an American
manhunt unlike any other leave it to
David to come up with a title like that
ever before or later if you are watching
tonight on c-span
you can order autographed copies of
shooting the moon by calling us at book
passage at eight hundred nine nine nine
seven nine oh nine or on our website
book passage calm for those of you who
are in the audience I see people who are
very have been very important in public
affairs over the last 40 years and I
really am thrilled to see you all here
tonight and to have the pleasure of
introducing David David is one of my
heroes and I think he's probably your
hero too in the 60s at the height of the
war David stood up for what was right he
could have skipped the Vietnam War as
the student at Stanford but as
president of a student body he stood up
and in fact ended up in jail for what he
believed now he could have had a student
deferment or he could have joined the
National Guard and then he would be
President
instead he is one of the most important
investigative journalists working today
his work has appeared in such stellar
places as the New York Times Magazine in
Rolling Stone he always seems to find
that something that everyone else has
missed his seven books including dreams
die hard the league and the recently
published in paperback The Last Stand
which details the takeover of the
Pacific lumber by Believe It or Not
Texans have been important and we're
happy to say controversial because they
really make us think in shooting the
moon David Harris brings us a really an
adventure story he Publishers Weekly
recently reviewed the book before it was
published and said that Harris's smartly
rendered admirably detailed work brings
us an investigative epic of government
malfeasance and retribution it reads
like an international thriller and
indeed it does and the names are names
you know and some we don't know one of
the major players is our good friend the
CIA director William Casey good old
Oliver North who I hope is watching
tonight is a major influence in this
book and someone that we learned some
new things about but mainly it's about
how three DEA agents caught the story of
what was really going on with our great
ally
and help her in the iran-contra time
Noriega and how they got the goods on
Noriega in spite of all kinds of
bureaucratic government obstacles it
took a David Harris to tell this story
to bring it to us in a succinct but
adventurous way and so I am extremely
proud to welcome to book passage tonight
David Harris for shooting the moon
[Applause]
Thank You Elaine it's always a pleasure
to be a book passage this is kind of my
home base as a writer it's ever since I
moved to Marin County and I've been
writing for a living for better than 30
years now and have written about
everything from the 60s to the National
Football League to the earth first to
the tycoon William s Paley and always
the question you have to answer is well
why did you choose this topic and you
should understand first off when you ask
a writer such a question that most of
the process of writing is spent trying
to discover that question for yourself
and it's only when you finally get a
book out there that you really
understand what it was that brought you
to this subject and that's certainly
true with shooting the moon but I have
answered that question so let me share
it with you I was brought to this first
because it's a one-of-a-kind story this
is indeed the only time this has ever
happened we are talking about an event
that is singular by definition once in
the entire two hundred and some-odd year
history of the United States of America
has the United States invaded a foreign
country seize that country's ruler
brought them back to the United States
charged tried and imprisoned them for
violations of American law conducted in
their own native land this is an
extraordinary precedent you have to go
back almost 600 years in world history
to find anything like it and as a
journalist you're always spending your
time taking generic stories and trying
to find the special significance of them
in this case I was confronted with a
story that had its own singular in us
before that I even began to approach it
and that was part of what brought me to
it the other part is that I'm a sucker
for lost episodes of history and this is
certainly one of those while Manuel
Noriega remains an extraordinarily
recognizable name in the United States
exactly what happened to him
lost in the shuffle by-and-large within
a year of sending a twenty thousand man
army in the Panama to arrest him we had
sent an even larger army into the Gulf
to to liberate Kuwait and the end result
of that among other things was that
nobody bothered to look at the last war
before that one and as a consequence
when Manuel Noriega finally was brought
to trial in the city of Miami in 1992
nobody paid much attention and he was
simply off the board and as a journalist
I am always drawn to answer that
question well what was it that happened
back there anyway and under the faith
that there really is a good story in
that and in this case there really is a
good story and the first thing you
should know about it is it's nonfiction
here we are this is not something that
I've invented it although you may wonder
when you read some of the stuff that
went on whether I invented it or not but
this is based on more than 150 hours the
interviews was more than two dozen
participants in the story it's based on
three years worth of hearings by three
different congressional committees and
the testimony that they were able to
elicit over a thousand pages of original
documents most of which were released
under the Freedom of Information Act
some four years worth of daily and
weekly journalism and some twelve books
that had already been written on the
subject and the end result is the true
story of an American manhunt unlike any
other ever and there are certainly
people who may not want this story in
circulation but when they raise their
voices
understand whether they want it in
circulation or not this is a true story
and it's a surprising story as well
because one would assume with a
one-of-a-kind event a singular is this
one that there was some overriding
intelligence up there that was directing
all of this to happen it's the kind of
story you expect somebody on top said we
want to go get this guy
and sent some people on the bottom out
to do it this was not how this story
happened this story begins at the bottom
and without the two DEA agents and an
assistant United States attorney in
Miami would never have happened the case
that eventually was made against Manuel
Noriega began as a very slim lead in a
cocaine investigation in the city of
Miami in 1985 and to these two DEA
agents kenny kennedy and steve grilling
and this assistant united states
attorney dick gregory pursued this lead
until it led them to an informant or it
led them to a cocaine violator who they
arrested and turned into an informant
who happened to be an old friend of
manuel noriega
and could testify among other things to
having carried money to Noriega from the
madyun cartel in order to get
transhipment rights for maydianne cartel
cocaine to flow through Panama and on to
the United States and also to get Mady
in cartel money flowing back from the
United States in the Panama into the
Panamanian banks to be laundered and
this case was made by these three law
enforcement officers without the support
of their bureaucracies over their heads
understand this nobody wanted this case
to be made this case was made because
under an internal DEA provision allowed
them to keep the case secret even from
their own bureaucracy until the case was
in front of a grand jury and it was no
longer possible for anyone to intervene
and derail the case suddenly it was part
of an official legal process and assets
had to be dealt with in an official
legal way so that the bureaucracy over
these men's heads were stuck with a fait
accompli when it suddenly rose up and
they did not want this to happen
understand Manuel Noriega while he
became the epitome of evil in the
American rendition of who he was and
certainly the epitome of ugliness
was a man who starts this story with a
lot of friends in just the right places
the chief amongst those is William Casey
who is at that point the new director of
the Central Intelligence Agency Noriega
was described by the American ambassador
to Panama as a quote protege of William
SK are cases when case I used to fly to
Panama he would get off the plane the
first thing he would say to his station
chief who welcomed him where is my boy
Noriega is what he would ask Noriega met
with the CIA station chief on a weekly
basis and the CIA looked after William
Casey William Casey's protege for the
next four years until it was finally too
late to do so
the DEA surprisingly enough that it was
two DEA agents who made the case on him
also had a lot invested in Manuel
Noriega Noriega have allowed the Drug
Enforcement Agency the right to board
Panamanian ships at high seas search
them for illicit drugs he had eliminated
his own domestic Panamanian marijuana
crop at the DEA is urging he had granted
the DEA access to internal banking
information in the Panamanian banking
industry that was in violation of
Panamanian law but was granted them as a
as a gift from Manuel Noriega also the
Department of Defense had a lot invested
in Manuel Noriega the United States at
that time maintained a military command
called the Southern Command in the
Panama Canal Zone which oversaw all
American military activity in the
hemisphere if you recall the 80s
American military activity in that
hemisphere was significant there was a
war going on in Guatemala in which
200,000 people eventually were killed
most of them executed not in fight there
was a war going on in El Salvador or
another hundred thousand people
eventually died there was a near war
going on in Honduras there was a
guerrilla operation being funded by the
United States and backed by the United
States going on Nicaragua
so there was plenty of military activity
to be overseen by the South calmness the
southern command was known and all of
that was in violation of the Panama
Canal treaties which explicitly state
that the American forces in the Panama
Canal Zone were only to be used for the
defense of the canal and they weren't to
be used for for any hemispheric
enterprises but once again Noriega was
prepared to turn a blind eye to that and
as a consequence the United States was
able to use its Southern Command in ways
that it would never been able to use had
he decided to enforce the treaties that
were in place now the reason all those
friends didn't prevent this story from
happening was because their own act fell
apart before Noriega did when a plane
crash in Nicaragua in the fall of 1986
and suddenly details begin coming out of
Nicaragua and then out of Washington and
then out of everywhere about how William
Casey and his underling Oliver North had
been running their own private war in
Central America against the wishes of
the United States Congress and the in
secret from the rest of the American
government and suddenly Oliver North who
had been one of one of Noriega backers
was out of the government and and facing
two to three years worth of criminal
trials and and congressional hearings
Casey was under siege and in the middle
of being under siege discovered a brain
tumor in his right brain that rendered
him speechless for the last six months
of his life and then he was dead and
suddenly the two biggest friends that
that Noriega had in Washington were no
longer there to look out for and this
scandal erupted just after Oliver North
had approached the Drug Enforcement
Administration and saying I understand
there's an investigation of Manuel
Noriega going on can't we do something
about it
before they got a chance to do something
about it they had their own act to have
to cover and that means that when this
story begins and the investigation
starts going full blast and Gregory and
Grille
and Kennedy have located their informant
a man named Floyd Carlton and are
keeping him in a Cell underneath the
Miami federal courthouse known as the
submarine that and extracting from him
every crowd counts of information they
can get about Manuel Noriega while
they're doing that nor Noriega s--
friends are on the run and some are
turning code most specifically the
Undersecretary of state for inner fires
Elliott Abrams who earlier in this story
had the first started out as the chief
opponent of a Manuel Noriega inside the
Reagan administration then under Casey's
urging because of Noriega is importance
to the to the entire iran-contra
operation that was going on had turned
and become a supporter of nor Noriega
inside the government in fact
suppressing actions against Noriega
because he was so important to what
Oliver North was trying to do with the
Contras once again at at this point when
the iran-contra starts falling apart and
and the Elliott Abrams is under extreme
pressure himself facing a petition from
Congress from over 150 congressmen
asking his resignation and that he if
not if he doesn't resign that he'd be
fired he's looking around for a way to
get himself back in some semblance of
stability in power and he chooses Manuel
Noriega is the way to do that and
suddenly becomes again the chief
spokesman against Manuel Noriega inside
the government at this point Abrams
pursues aggressively a policy that
ultimately leads him to propose for the
first time in 1988 that the United
States government effectively invade
Panama send a team of commandos after
Manuel Noriega arrest them and bring him
back to the United States in order to
try and make this case inside the
administration and get them to adopt
this policy he ends up in a battle
Royall with the Department of Defense
led by the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff whose position is if the
Panamanians want to get rid of Noriega
fine and good let them get rid of
Noriega why should we get rid of Noriega
for them why are Americans supposed to
die in order to to benefit a series of
Panamanians who probably earn far more
than ten any of these people who are
going to die for them do that the
military plans that Abrams were
proposing would end up in a military
disaster that the United States was far
too vulnerable all these arguments were
made inside the administration and
Abrams lost at that point the cudgel
against Manuel Noriega inside the
administration is taken up by George
Bush at that point is Vice President and
George Bush Anders this story with a
Noriega problem which is as he is
running for president while sitting as
vice president he is questioned about
his relationship with Noriega dating
from when Bush himself ran the CIA and
the Ford administration and at that
initially Bush denied ever having had
contact with Noriega then a picture
surfaced of him and Noriega sitting next
to each other in the in the Panama City
Airport and the Bush has to correct
himself and admit that in fact they'd
had two different encounters one in 1976
one in 1983 but the damage politically
at that point is done
I mean his opponents are putting out
that bumper sticker saying bush in
Noriega in 88 you know they can work
together
so his suddenly his biggest political
problem is what to do about the this
linkage of him to this that this tinhorn
dictator down in Panama and the answer
to that is he becomes the chief
spokesman for getting rid of Noriega
inside the administration when the
administration negotiates a deal with
Noriega to get him to resign in Panama
in exchange for having the charges
dropped the man who tries to block that
is George Bush he is unsuccessful
blocking it but then Noriega himself
backs out of the deal and the deal falls
apart
six months later George Bush is
president at that point Manuel Noriega
is days are numbered not because Bush
immediately jumps in on the case of
Manuel Noriega
but because Bush develops a second
Noriega problem in his first year as
president after Noriega steals the
elections in Panama and refuses to allow
them to take place and then after a coup
in Panama or attempted coup in Panama to
throw Noriega out which fails largely
because the Bush administration does
nothing to support it suddenly George
Bush in the fall of 1989 is looking at a
second Noriega problem which is merging
with what was if you remember those days
known as the wimp factor and the
question whether George Bush really had
enough hair on his chest to be President
of the United States now in the meantime
while all this is happening in the Bush
administration you should understand
that the criminal case has virtually
fallen apart that the freemen who made
the case one has been the assistant
United States Attorney Dick Gregory has
been run out of the United States
Attorney's Office Kenny Kennedy the DEA
supervisor who allowed this case to go
forward has had his career crushed and
essentially frozen in place for the rest
of his tenure at the DEA and Steve
really the case agent who actually made
it has been worked over by the
bureaucracy and eventually told to drop
the case the case files that were used
to indict Noriega had been spread out in
the justice system filing and basically
disappeared until suddenly in September
of 1989 Steve really the case agent gets
a call and
told to put this case back together
again just in case three months later
the twenty thousand man army invades
Panama and with the idea of seizing
Manuel Noriega they seize Panama easily
enough only takes American forces about
five hours to conquer Panama but they
can't find Noriega who was on the run
inside Panama but doing among other
things sleeping in graveyards because
he's convinced the Americans will not
come into a graveyard after dark they'll
be too scared eventually at his wits end
he decides to take refuge in the Vatican
embassy in Panama City which he does and
since the embassies are in are in
violent by a diplomatic understanding
the Americans can't go in there after
him so they set up their loudspeakers
around the embassy I'm sure everybody
remembers this and they play rock and
roll at top volume it's like I fought
the law and the law won which didn't
influence Noriega at all but it drove
the the Vatican personnel inside the
embassy crazy until they finally asked
the Americans to stop and several days
later Noriega on his own decided to
surrender and was read his Miranda
rights and brought back to the United
States to stand trial and that's the
story but this is more than just the
story and this is this is also populated
not just by information while there's
plenty of information in this but this
is a story that's populated by
characters who go out and do things it
is a piece of history that with the
emphasis on story and a collection of
information that is really written like
it's fiction as opposed to nonfiction
and you get to follow these people over
their shoulder as one of the craziest
episodes in American history comes down
and you will have trouble believing that
it really happened when you see the way
it really did happen but I hope you will
I hope you'll read it and I hope you'll
enjoy it and at this stage of the game
I'm supposed to take questions so
we got a question well I just bought
your vote today after hearing you are
Criswell oh thank you lovely description
Miami and since I haven't read it I
wonder if at any point you deal with the
fact that Noriega was one of many
unsavory dictators trained by the United
States at the Army School of the
Americas only in passing I had my hands
full with one unsavory dictator but
certainly the the distance of the school
and the involvement of the Southern
Command in that kind of activity is is
established in the book and it we and
the Southern Command continues to do
that today even though they can't do it
in Panama was proceeded
kind of governments of Panama by a
corrupt but nonetheless populist left
spouting rhetoric in general named for
Rios who died in an airplane or a
helicopter crash is there any evidence
that Noriega or US intelligence was
involved in that crash there's no the
question was whether in the death of
Omar Torrijos who was the strong man who
preceded Noriega although there were
there were couple in between
Torrio's and Noriega but whether who
died in a plane crash whether there was
any evidence that the United States
award Noriega had been involved in that
plane crash the only evidence is there's
an episode that happens in the book
where Noriega Steef of staff in the
Panamanian Defense Force one of a group
of three who seized power together is
forced out by Noriega and in response to
being forced out he begins making public
statements about what's been going on in
Panama and one of the statements he
makes was that Noriega was involved in
sabotaging the Omar Torrijos plane but
other than that there is no there is no
such evidence how you did your
interviews and curious as to whether you
found people willing to talk and did you
do you no interviews in person did you
have to cut deals with people how did
you identify people well let me start
the last part first I identified the
identified people and when I approached
a story like this I sparked by trying to
deal with with everything that's out
there in the public record already
before I get there so reading the
congressional hearings reading the books
that have been written on it reading the
newspaper coverage etc etc and in the
course of going through all that I'm
constantly collecting names in all of
this there are names that come up and so
at the end of this stage of the process
I usually have a pile of note cards with
all these names on and then I sort
through those and begin to figure out
which ones are essential for me and who
start with and then I start chasing
these people and I see what what I get
certainly there are plenty of people who
didn't want to talk to me Oliver North
did not talk to me he did not even
answer my phone call
Elliott Abrams did not talk to me
although Elliott Abrams did have one of
his assistants call me and say he wasn't
going to talk to me and when I continued
to pester he then had one of his
assistants send me a fax saying that he
would that's as close as I got to him on
the other hand I was surprised by some
of the people who did talk to me
certainly the case agent involved in
this Steve Grilli was a great source of
information for me and someone who had
to be ordered to talk to me to begin
with I mean to talk to an active DEA
agent you have to get the permission of
the of the agency first and they did not
particularly want me to talk to Grilli I
guess because they kept dragging their
feet and finally they wanted me to talk
to some other people first who I knew
weren't essential to my story but I went
through the drill and talked to those
people first and finally I got to talk
to Grilli and and and Grilli was
extraordinarily useful to me you know I
I can't cut many deals with people
because I don't have anything to deal
you know I mean when you're in the
situation of a journalist you know it's
not like I don't pay people for
information and I not only don't have
money but I don't approve of paying
people for information on top of that I
don't you know I don't have many favors
I can I can go out there and offer
people except the chance to have their
story told but you'd be amazed how many
people like to have their stories told I
mean that that and once you can break
through the sort of automatic distance
that you begin with as journalists to a
potential source you you be amazed how
much people will volunteer Liberty with
what they were telling you or did they
ask to have their quotes checked or
well in some cases I I did check quotes
and and and run this all by people in
order to you know particularly where it
was it was sensitive stuff that that but
you know the rules when you're working
as a journalist are if you talk to a
journalist it's their you know you don't
have to have a second transaction you
know you know you're on the record from
the date from the moment you walk in the
door and and I certainly play it that
way and some people you know I offer the
opportunity to in particular cases to be
anonymous if it's something of
sensitivity that they're worried about
it's gonna back up on them but by and
large it's just a straight honest
transaction hey I'm doing this book and
you're an important player in it and I'd
like to get your version of what went on
and it's mostly cold calls but you'd be
amazed how many people respond to that
this information
- information contacted information to
neutralize the impact of a book
I wonder if yours has been greeted with
that kind of treatment and whether you
have received that kind of encounter
well today is the publication the
official publication date officially
this book exists today so whether I'm
gonna catch any of that or not remains
to be seen
certainly I'm familiar with what you
talked about and but you know at this
point I can't say it's gonna happen I
think most people would would who have
an interest in suppressing the story
simply try not to pay attention to it
but I certainly hope there's somebody
out there who tries to suppress this
story we need some headlines something
big politically that had lost him the
protection of the people who had
protected him and I seem to remember
there was some speculation at the time
about it was something about having in
some way helped the Nicaraguans
something about passage of ships or
something like that that there had been
some and so I wondered if you had run
across that or if you had any theory of
your own
we certainly run across all kinds of
speculation but in in this case the
biggest thing that kept people from
helping him was the iran-contra scandal
because not only did some people fall
from power as a consequence but more
importantly inside the government
suddenly there was a searchlight on this
kind of activity and people were faced
with the prospect of having to just
publicly stand up in support of this
thug running Panama and while they were
perfectly prepared in private to support
that thug in any number of other thugs
the prospect of doing that in the public
glare that was going on was more than
people could take I mean for example
there's at the final stages of the
indictment before
they go to the grand jury and get an
actual true bill which indict manuel
noriega fir for 12 counts of violation
the Racketeer Influenced Corrupt
Organizations Act the Gregory and Grilli
and Kennedy along with with Leon Kilmer
who was the United States Attorney from
Miami all go to Washington to inform the
powers-that-be that this is what's gonna
happen and they go through it they go
through a vetting at that at the Justice
Department where they you know the
Justice lawyers all go through the
indictment and make sure that it's all
legally correct etcetera etc and then
Kellner by himself has taken to a couple
meetings the first with with a series of
underlings from various departments
including Elliott Abrams was one of the
people who was at that meeting and then
from there they're taken over to the
White House where Kellner is brought in
front of the National Security Council
or in the National Security Council part
of the White House to a meeting there
and at issue is whether the president is
going to exercise his powers under a
presidential directive that allows him
to suppress a criminal indictment if he
finds it's in the national interest and
if that criminal indictment conflicts
with with activities of other parts of
the government so this is this is
something that exists out there and the
question was whether the Reagan was
going to invoke it or not but of course
to invoke it in the middle of the
iran-contra scandal would have been out
of the question
so Keller ends up at this meeting and
they ask him some questions about the
indictment and they sort of go through
it and there's a point in the meeting
where the guy who is chairing the
meeting says well is there anybody here
who has an objection to this indictment
and nobody moves you know nobody says a
thing although later after Keller leaves
the meeting there's you know these guys
are talking to each other about what you
know about how can the you know how can
the United States attorney from Miami
set American foreign policy and what are
we ever you know I mean this is not
something they like to have happen but
it's happening and they can't say
anything about it and finally but just
just before Kellner is gonna leave the
meeting yeah one the guy from the State
Department could meet
says says to him well you know sometimes
in the course of my work I have contact
with Manuel Noriega and now that you've
indicted him what do you expect me to do
when I see him and Kellner decides to go
for humor in the situation so he says
well you could read him his Miranda
rights and nobody in the room laughs
it's not even a chuckle so it was the
iran-contra there was the big reason and
yeah because you know Noriega had had
done all the things he had promised the
Americans to do it's not like he he
double-crossed on Nicaragua I mean he
you know he was he provided North with
the dummy Panamanian corporations that
could hide his activities he allowed
Panama to be used as as a as a
transshipment point for Israeli arms
which were then set into the Contras he
helped the Americans recruit the pilot
the bush pilots who interestingly enough
were also the same pilots who were
flying for the maybe in cartel in the in
Panama I mean they're the same guy to
fly guns into the into the contrast and
often those contra planes of flew guns
into the Contras through cocaine out on
the way back there's plenty of public
testimony as to as to that and Noriega
even while out in a Panamanian
intelligence agent to be part of a North
scheme that they ended up planting a
bomb in in Managua and blowing up an
army barracks in in Managua which the
Contras then claimed as their as you
know as a sign of their political
viability when in fact it had been this
Panamanian operative ivenna hired the
British mercenary who are the ones who
had actually planted the explosive but
Noriega had been as he put it a good
friend he'd done what the Americans
asked and he assumed his ass would be
covered because he had done it and so
you know I mean one of the ironic
responses here is after Noriega is
indicted that one his personal reaction
was one of being hurt I mean just on a
personal level you know I did all this
for these guys and they do this to me
you know I mean what's going on here
although at the time I doubt if he put
much weight on this indictment I mean
the notion I mean even after the
indictment even with all the people who
had you know who pursued this indictment
and pursued this case nobody thought
this was ever going to become a real
legal issue I mean that because it to do
it it had to they had to have Noriega
and you know the joke at the time was
well what are they gonna do send an army
down to get him to indict someone and
you can see that rising from the bottom
the decision to send twenty thousand
troops soon has to come from the top
well he did come from the top we made it
at the top trying to trying to figure
out what to do with this hot potato that
they'd been handed and fitted into their
own agendas and the reason that there
was an Army's went down there is because
it fit into the agenda the political
agenda of George Bush and interestingly
enough when it came time to actually
just make the decision okay we're gonna
send the troops in there was discussion
of a number of different options but one
of the things that nobody talked about
was what precedent they were setting I
mean there was no discussion about well
you know can we get some perspective on
this what does this look like from a
different angle because the logic that
sent this armed force down there to
arrest this wanted fugitive from the
United States could equally be used to
support an action by the Iranians who
being totally offended by American
videos and and which are clear
violations of Islamic law invade the
United States seize Bill Clinton for
having taken contributions from the
video industry and take him back to Iran
and try them for violating Islamic law
what's the you know that the logic is
essentially the same but the
implications of what people were about
to do was not what got discussed either
in private in the decision-making
circles or in public I mean by this time
publicly Manuel Noriega had become the
symbol of everything evil and nasty and
bad and to not want to go get in a
Manuel Noriega was somehow a violation
of everything
that America was supposed to stand for
but it isn't the first time we've got
caught up in our own testosterone with
all the iran-contra fallout going on as
to just how the Bush administration was
able to get so much substantial public
opinion in favor of or in favor of the
invasion and and supporting what they do
well I think it one can't underestimate
the degree to to which Noriega was
transformed into a public archetype I
mean I you know most of us were all
around during that time and if you
remember you know there was a constant
barrage of stories about Manuel Noriega
and what a bad guy he was and certainly
he was a bad guy there's no there's no
issue here about you know this is
somebody who marine county would take as
a dog catcher for about ten seconds you
know I mean this is not somebody anybody
wants to wants to live under on the
other hand in a in Central America where
the government Anika in Guatemala is
executing 200,000 Indians with their
hands tied behind their back where the
government in El Salvador was running
death squads in and out where the
government Honduras is doing the same
thing where the government in Nika and
Nicaragua is he has certainly
suppressing rights if not doing worse
than that he suddenly you get down to
Panama on Noriega it looks pretty good
you know I mean they you know there's we
certainly had a few people killed but it
wasn't really only a few people and you
know he certainly was a crook but you
know the best quote best quote I heard
it ever heard about Panama was from from
the general who ran SOUTHCOM who who
quoted a Panamanian president describing
Panama not so much as a country but a
tribe of pirates you know this you know
this is a place where that makes its
living taking a piece of the action as
it comes through whatever the action may
be and all of the talk about
about the dangers of international money
laundering international money longer
laundering is Panama's business and the
the people we supported against Noriega
were as deeply involved in it as Noriega
everybody there is and it's one of the
it is the Panamanian economy is the
Panamanian banking system which is
second only to Switzerland as a place to
go hide your money if you if you need to
hide it from people so you know I think
to Noriega never got seen in that kind
of context and that was the other
contributing factor was there was there
were a series of encounters between the
Panamanian forces and the American
forces some of which were provoked some
of which just spontaneously happened
that built up this kind of hysteria if
you remember the days right before the
Panamanian invasion you know there were
people being stopped at roadblocks and
and one American officer was killed by
after running a roadblock there were
several incidents like that that beat
the drum up and Noriega contributed to
it I mean Noriega during that time was
filmed by American television crews at
rallies in Panama City you know waving a
machete and eating on his chest and you
know saying that great girls will never
get me and you know and interestingly
enough after Noriega had been imprisoned
in the Miami Federal Correctional
Institution he has been there ever ever
since his conviction except for one for
two episodes one the first of which was
when a hurricane was approaching Miami
and so they had to evacuate the federal
prisoners so Noriega was taken by two
federal marshals up to the Atlanta
penitentiary and along the way you know
they had Noriega right in the back seat
and the two marshals in the front seat
you know and Noriega speaks a little
English and they you know they got they
got
a little thing going there in the car
and they were friends and talking and
finally one of these united states
marshals turns through Noriega and
talking about this incident when Noriega
bleeding on his chest and waving a
machete and said you know what in the
world ever possessed you to do that and
Noriega looked a little sheepish and
says I guess I [ __ ] up also the other
factor there is that you know Americans
have always thought of Panama not as a
foreign country but is their possession
and even though this all happens at a
time when we're giving up all of our
claims to the Panama Canal Zone but the
it's it's a stretch for some people's
minds to even think that that there you
can invade Panama you know and
interestingly enough in the organization
of the State Department while there is
you know the Central American desk and a
South American desk there is no desk
that covered Panama historically in the
State Department Panama was a whole
separate thing because of course we had
created it back when it first started
did you find in your research any
evidence that that the invasion was
fueled to any extent by lingering
resentment on the right about handing
over well I said I I'm sure that that
was a contributor among some people
support for it I have no doubt about
that I think it probably a bigger
contributor was remember this was the
first significant military action taken
after the Vietnam War and I think there
was a real what became a full-blown urge
in the Gulf War was a less some a little
less than full-blown urge at this time
which was to show that we could go out
and exercise force and do so
successfully and to eliminate what was
being called the Vietnam syndrome and
certainly it was apparent in what we the
force we sent down there I mean this was
a real pile on I mean 20 thousand
American troops
were needless to say more than a match
for the Panamanian Defense Force and
everybody everybody in the American
military wanted to get their little
piece of the action
I mean the Air Force sent down its new
stealth bombers for example I mean this
is against the use against the country
that doesn't even have an Air Force you
know or a radar you know I mean then the
necessity of using the stealth that's
probably a little overblown and so I
think that was probably a stronger urge
than than the other one of the tips that
were made David by you or any of the
other any officials to actually
interview Noriega and what are your
goals and expectations of the book well
I tried very hard to interview a Noriega
I tried first through his legal defense
team you know it's sending a long letter
which to get which I hope they would
deliver and then after six months I
found they hadn't delivered and because
the guy who was in charge of dealing
with in the defense team of dealing with
the general as they call him on a daily
basis was up on charges of money
laundering himself and was having them
having a bad day so I finally got
someone else in the defense team who
would carry my letter to him and he
brought back a verbal response saying
well the general wants to know what you
want to talk about so I then sent him a
long letter detailing all the subjects
that I would like to discuss with him
none of which were his criminal
liability I mean the last thing you need
to interview a guy about who's been on
trial in the United States criminal
course is his criminal activity that's
all public record you know and you know
what I wanted to talk to him about was
more about him and who he was and and as
I pointed out I said what do you got to
lose you know I mean you're already the
epitome of evil I mean I can't do any
more than that to you and I might you
know I might be able to soften some of
that who knows
but my arguments were not persuasive at
the time Noriega was awaiting a sentence
reduction hearing and I had one of my
theories at the time was that he might
be trying to sandbag and wait for that
sentence reduction hearing which
eventually happened and his sentence was
reduced from 40 years to 30 years and at
that sentence reduction hearing
interesting enough the American
ambassador to Panama testified on his
behalf the CIA station chief from Panama
testified on his behalf and the CIA
station chief saying he'd gotten a raw
deal and the Panama that ambassador
testifying that he in fact had done a
great number of things for America and
that he ought to be his sentence ought
to be reduced accordingly the trial
judge reduced the sentence on the basis
of that Noriega as co-conspirators had
gotten such significantly smaller
sentences that his had to be brought
somewhat in line with theirs but you
understand you know if you look at this
from the standpoint of an arrest I mean
as part of the reason I wrote this story
as a cops-and-robbers story first and
foremost was if you look at this from a
standpoint of an arrest it suddenly
looks very different I mean if the
Justice Department sent 20,000 men into
an American city to arrest the fugitive
burned down at one of the city's
neighborhoods in the process killed 400
people at least and had 27 of their own
people killed all to arrest this one guy
you would the questions would be raised
you know what are we doing here and on
top of that once they had him
they then forgave the several life
sentences in about a thousand years
worth of prison sentences on about 15
different individuals to get them to
testify against Noriega at his trial so
there was this calculated decision to go
out and get Noriega and the flip side of
that of course is that by the DEA zone
estimates within a year after the arrest
of Manuel Noriega there was more cocaine
being trans hipped through Panama than
there had been under Noriega rule so
I think you know I always try to tell
the story and let everybody draw their
own conclusions afterwards and this is
true to that pattern but it's all out
there for you guys to figure out what
you think of have this activity let me
take one last question link the general
with mr. Bush when he was running the
CIA well there is the question was if
there any evidence to link and Manuel
Noriega to George Bush when George Bush
was running the Ford administration CIA
and what the evidence we have is Manuel
Noriega wrote in as told to memoir after
he went to prison in which he recounts a
meeting with George Bush in 1976 when
Bush was head of this the CIA and
according to Noriega and worship self
was never made a comment about this and
it consistently said he will not discuss
anything he did the CIA director because
it's a violation of his over the oath he
took when he when he took over the job
but according to Noriega their
discussion concerned the fact that at
the time the Panama Canal treaties were
being negotiated and had hit a sort of
stalled point and Noriega in 1976 was
simply the intelligence chief in in
Panama and Panama was being run by Omar
Torrijos
and the Torrio's and Noriega approached
the CIA station chief in in Managua not
Managua excuse me in Panama City
about what they could do to get this to
get negotiations off the dime and moving
again and the station chief suggested
that something that made it clear how
vulnerable that canal was to potential
terrorism would be a great idea so
according to Noriega under this a group
of panamanians was taken by the CIA to
the United States trained then they
infiltrated the Canal Zone and planted a
couple bombs that were harmless I mean
they were not designed to really blow
anything up they were designed that
to make a show of blowing something up
and the the question that he and Bush
had to talk about was what to you know
how to handle this
now the explosions had happened and they
were being investigated by the Southern
Command and you know Bush wanted to make
sure Noriega wasn't gonna spill the
beans and Noriega according to him a
short Bush that he would not and that
was the one personal contact that
happened between them when Bush ran the
CIA well thank you very much guys buy a
lot of books read them tell your friends
[Applause]
David Harris is the author of shooting
the moon the true story of an American
manhunt unlike any other ever it's
published by Little Brown and company to
find out more visit their website at TW
bookmark com 48 hours of nonfiction
books on TV you're watching book TV on
c-span 2 coming up actress Jane Meadows
widow of entertainers Steve Allen leads
a discussion with their son Bill Allen
about the late talk-show host last book
which challenged popular culture to
raise its standards and after that a
former member of the Nazi youth movement
Friedrich to Bach gives a talk with his
co-author Burnett Rosner Hungarian Jew
and survivor of Auschwitz about their
book an uncommon friendship
next week on book TV an encore booknotes
interview with Harry Stein ethics
columnist for The Wall Street Journal on
his memoir titled how I accidentally
joined the vast right-wing conspiracy
and found inner peace then Lynn Olson
explains her book on the lives of key
women in the civil rights movement
including hi to be wells Ella Baker and
Eleanor Roosevelt and later from this
year's Virginia festival of the book
will show you world war two veterans
describing their books on the conflict
[Music]
why is it more difficult to write a
memoir than a novel next Sunday joined
book TV at the Princeton Club in New
York City for the New Yorker festival
where the private lives panel includes
Frank McCourt Mary Karr Martyn Amos and
Dave Eggers whose memoir a heartbreaking
work of staggering genius has spent 18
weeks on the New York Times nonfiction
paperback bestseller list I don't know
if I could ever write nonfiction in any
way shape or form again having even-even
profile eccentric like in the magazine
article or anything like that which I
used to do have the responsibility is so
grave